the difference between editing revising
and just plain skimming your work or a
page that you've done for the day
either skimming it praising it or
skimming it unfortunately trashing it
so what are the difference between the
three editing revising and skimming or
are they all kind of the same in some
sense skimming is what I do when I don't
know what I'm gonna do then you're kind
of and okay so editing editing revising
skimming interesting I don't know how
often I ever skim a skin would be like a
copy edit or I literally kind of just I
don't even I'm I'm just tired and I'm
like okay I'm just gonna read this
through and maybe oh I can't remember
Eric maybe it was Eric Roth he's a
screenwriter is he the one who did
Benjamin Button and what he talks about
when he writes he always starts at the
beginning and reads through up to where
every day he reads through up to where
he's gonna start writing and then writes
from there and of course in the reading
through there's little things you want
to change so so I'll do that but for
actual and and then there's editing like
copy editing and I make tons of typos so
I definitely do that as well and then I
give it to other people to edit and then
I edit it again and then there's it's
still a mess but but revision I try to
approach it as a very specific process
whereby I go into it with a plan I'm
like okay this is a scene and the scene
has these building blocks and it's weak
in a certain like there's a beginning a
middle and an end and it needs some kind
of adjustment and and so I try to look
within that scene at kind of the
polarity you know like there's a little
tiny usually a little tiny character arc
within the scene right somebody
you know opens the door for their date
hell you know I'm hopeful and then they
have a little conversation and by the
time they get to the car they're feeling
like this is going to be great or by the
time they get to the car they're like
this is already a disaster and those are
two different things and so a lot of
times I think the revision process is is
you've kind of looked at the scene in
terms of tracking what the character is
gonna go through throughout the entire
script where does where does the scene
fit into it how is it setting up for
other things what does it need to do so
I look at it in terms of function and in
terms of those building blocks and I so
when I revise I have a very I'm like now
it does this and I want it to either do
this better or I want it to do something
different
that's my ideal that's my ideal revision
you don't always get that luxury
sometimes you're just like this sucks
and somehow I've got to make it seem
better and then you're just fiddling but
but revision in its ideal form for me is
that editing skimming and revision I
think to a certain extent I agree with
all of that for me when I'm writing
something I do tend to just write out
just completely and and then go back and
read what I've written before I go to
bed or before I give it up and see if I
can go a little you know and and then do
the the the tweaking and even to a
certain extent see how much further I
can go until I hit a wall and then the
next morning I go back and reread like I
don't I I do a lot of self editing
whether it be for small words or how can
I say this better how can it sound more
real
how can it sound more authentic because
I think as a journalist ice
I write differently than I speak and so
one of the challenges for me with
dialogue has been listening to how
people speak and the cadence to which
people speak and that's why going to
cafes was important to me because
getting the rhythm of a particular
speech pattern was important to me I
would listen to my friends and it
actually screenwriting made me a better
listener
because I would listen to what there was
what people were saying and how they
were saying it and what inflections they
gave it so when I when I edit it's like
a mic heat am I in am i keeping that
rhythm is that Katyn still flowing
so I'm looking and editing for specific
things and then with the revision like
with what Barrington was saying you know
I'm looking at the overall and and what
can make the overall better I guess the
editing and skimming kind of go hand in
hand for me it's like I'm doing that all
at one time looking for different things
but I actually like the process of
editing I'm at it I'm working as an
editor now for Los Angeles review books
and you know working on other people's
work and looking at how to make that
their work better because that was
always one of the things that I loved
about my editors is that they kept the
voice that I was looking for and in my
voice in the story they just made it
that much better and so that's what
editing for me is it's a it's a way to
make things better not always did
editors make it better but those that
did that was where I found you know a
strength and keeping that voice and
making sure the best of that voice came
out so what I hope when I
editing is just honing in on those
things that really make that voice sound
authentic and I think to our credit one
of the things that people said it was
that each of the characters had their
own distinct voice and so that was
really gratifying and so now it's just
the revising and making sure all that
great voice you know is in context with
a great story and a strong sensibility
and good conflict and deep meaningful
you know great deep meaningful story
story yes it's something that you said
in there also made me think of of kind
of you know I think my mind tends to to
jump to this kind of prose editing but I
think hearing her talk about voice one
other kind of editing that that you'll
do is you'll take a pass so you'll do a
dialogue pass especially if you if we we
don't get to do as many passes as we'd
like because it seems like we're always
writing to a deadline but but you know
given the amount of time like you'll do
a dialogue pass and then you'll do kind
of a a pass for geography and a pass for
like certain characters like you'll do
you'll do a pass where you're just kind
of like tracking where one character is
emotionally like do you know do they
have a logical progression of emotion
between if you know where the beginning
is and you know where the end is or is
there some place you know in the middle
where they're in a scene but they're
getting kind of lost and you can just
put it in a reaction that shows that
something's changing in them you know if
they're reacting in a certain way to
what's going on so that it like it's
something that you see on the screen
more right so trying to to think of me
so yeah so you do your main character
pass sometimes you'll do like a pass for
a second
characters so you'll do those kind of
different passes and I guess that would
also fall under editorial
you